Guten Morgen, Linus. Guten Morgen. Äh ich habe, ich habe gehört, es ist jetzt Jagdszeit, wen wollen wir denn jetzt äh mal jagen.
Ich will die nächsten vier Jahre Nepper, Schlepper, Bauernfänger, Hetzer und Brunnenvergifter jagen.
Lokbodennetzpolitik Nummer zweihunderteinunddreißig vom fünften Oktober zwanzig siebzehn,
Frühmorgens sitzen wir hier wieder und äh schütteln den Kopf über äh das ein oder andere,
und ähm ja und äh unseren Kater vom Wochenende haben wir aber schon, haben wir schon abgeschüttelt, oder?
Den haben wir abgeschüttelt. Wir waren zu Gast im Ruhrgebiet.
Da waren wir überhaupt Gast, ne? Wir waren beide so ein bisschen, ne? Wir waren
Gast und Moderation von geschätzten Kollegen methodisch inkorrekt, die ihre hundertste Sendung gefeiert haben, obwohl sie ja schon eigentlich im Sendungsplan schon weitere hinausgeschlossen sind, aber man will sich ja die schönen runden Zahlen nicht nehmen lassen, nicht wahr?
Ja und hat einen Spaß. Da wird sicherlich zu irgendeiner Zeit eine Videoaufzeichnung von dieser ganzen Veranstaltung ähm kommen,
Wir haben bisschen rummoderiert, ein wenig gesungen und äh auch ein wenig philosophiert und ähm ja zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt sind wir noch nicht ganz klar, in welcher Reihenfolge, in welcher Aufmachung, welchen
Paket die Sirum das Ganze äh die Netze erreichen wird, aber da werdet ihr sicherlich demnächst von hören.
Das äh C drei Wok hat auch da wieder freundlich unterstützt und ich habe gestern noch mit äh Danimo kurz gequatscht. Das wird jetzt gerade aufbereitet und,
geschnitten und wird dann wahrscheinlich der der YouTube-Öffentlichkeit zum Kommentieren.
Ja, wird aber sicherlich noch ein paar Tage dauern, weil die.
Das war's. Äh.
Alles sehr provisorisch so, man merkte, dass sich das erstmal rund schleifen muss dieser Event.
Wie das so ist.
Wie das eben so ist.
Ähm bleibt uns irgendwie noch kurz zu danken, wann ja waren auch äh viele Leute da, die uns angesprochen haben.
Mhm. Stimmt.
Herzlichen Dank und freundlichen Gruß einmal in die Allgemeinheit.
Ja genau und äh vielleicht auch nochmal so der Hinweis, also wenn ihr euch wenn ihr uns seht bei irgendwie solchen Events, dann traut euch einfach da einfach äh uns kurz anzusprechen. Wir haben das gerne.
Nur nicht wundern, wenn wir schwer. Also man muss ja auch gucken, wie man in Gespräch kommt. Das ist ja eigentlich das Problem immer.
Ja gut, ich habe da etwas Übung. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht.
Äh äh kommt ist jetzt immer ein also nicht Übel nehmen, wenn wenn ich dann mal nicht genau weiß, was ich antworten soll. Ich bin da nicht so geübt wie der Tim.
Ja genau, wenn ich nicht weiß, was sie antworten soll, äh schreibt mir gleich eine ausführliche Mail dazu und wenn ich das beim nächsten Mal berücksichtigen.
So
Dann haben wir Sendung, letzte Sendung ist ähm etwas länger her, der wir waren mit der Vorbereitung für methodisch inkorrekt. Tatsächlich sehr,
Stark gefordert und haben deswegen nicht mehr die Zeit gehabt, noch eine andere Sendung zu machen.
Ähm deswegen ist die letzte Sendung länger her und war vor der Bundestagswahl. Ja, die letzte Sendung war vor der Bundestagswahl.
Also die meist die letzte. Ach so ja okay vor der Bundesregierung. Ja ja.
Letzte Sendung war vor der Bundestagswahl.
Und das war ja auch so ein bisschen.
Da hatten wir so grob eine eine Wahlnichtempfehlung gegeben. Also wen man nicht wählen kann.
Ja gen.
Es wurde äh das gab äh den ein oder anderen hitzigen Kommentar, was uns einfiele.
Und er ist mir aufgefallen, dass äh dass mir mehrfach vorgeworfen wurde. Ich würde alle AfD-Wähler pauschal als Nazis verurteilen, das tue ich gar nicht. Ich sage einfach nur, dass alle AfD-Wähler Idioten sind.
Ja
Also da muss ich dann nochmal korrigieren, das ist offenbar falsch äh wahrgenommen worden. Insofern korrigiere ich mich da gerne.
Ja, das ist ja so schwierige äh äh Debatte, ne, so wie geht man damit jetzt um und so, das äh,
Ich denke ich bleibe da auch bei meiner äh Meinung, ich habe mich jetzt in den Kommentaren nicht zu ausführlich äh gemeldet. Grundsätzlich sehe ich's einfach so,
Man mag ja, man darf ja gerne äh,
Meinung vertreten und man kann da auch für sich persönlich bei so einer Wahl seine Schlüsse daraus ziehen und sicherlich auch mal auf den ein oder anderen Protestzug,
aufspringen, aber bei mir persönlich ist da einfach eine harte äh Grenze in dem Moment, wo sich halt so ein Protest darin äußert, dass man halt
Leuten, die einfach äh mindestens eine grobe Unverantwortlichkeit äh gegenüber dieser Gesellschaft an den Tag legen, wenn man solchen Leuten irgendwie Raum gibt, dann,
dann geht das einfach nicht. So.
Ich denke also so eine grundsätzliche Anforderung, die ich an eine Partei stelle, der ich meine Stimme geben würde.
Ist, dass sie in irgendeiner Form ein Konzept definiert.
Wie sie bestimmte Probleme lösen will. Ne, also Wahlkampf bedeutet im Prinzip würde ich erwarten,
So stelle ich mir das vor, man äh das,
Dass die Bevölkerung wird gebeten, doch eine ähm Richtungsentscheidung für die nächsten vier Jahre zu treffen und die Parteien bewerben sich. Und diese, die Parteien benennen ein Problem.
Und mögen doch bitte ähm mehr oder weniger belastbares Konzept vorbringen. Wie sie denn dieses Problem, Gedenken zu lösen, ne? Deswegen hatte ich mich ja auch hier über.
Im Idealfall nicht nur ein Problem, sondern.
Mehrere können sie, mehrere, wenn sie wenn's genau benennen den diese was weiß ich, bewerten den Ist-Zustand und sagen da ist vorne, da wollen wir hin,
ja? Das ist das, was wir machen wollen. Und jetzt kann wird sofort der der Kommentar kommen, dass keine einzige Partei diesem Anspruch äh gerecht geworden ist, den ich hier,
habe, dass man meine vernünftige Positionsbestimmung einen Schritt nach vorne findet. Das ist äh das ist ein Punkt, der relativ richtig ist. Aber man erkennt dann Parteien,
die im Prinzip nur ein Problem beschreien ohne auch nur in, in den, in die Nähe eines tragfähigen Konzeptes,
der Bewältigung dieses Problems zu kommen. Das ist das, was man äh eine unseriöse Partei nennt, ja? Die äh das wird ähm mal zurecht mal zu Unrecht jeder Partei vorgeworfen,
Linken Partei immer mal wieder, aber jeder anderen auch, ja? Ich hab's ja in der letzten Sendung auch zum Beispiel in Grün vorgeworfen, zumindest einem einem derer Plakate dieses,
Häuser denen, die drin wohnen, Plakat und so, ne? Also, dass es einfach nur Quatsch ist. Ähm.
Aber die AfD ist da in keiner Form irgendwo in der Nähe eines tragfähigen Konzeptes und ähm es gab ja auch in den in den Kommentaren dann äh Versuche da mal,
Die Tragfähigkeit der Konzepte der AfD zu zeigen oder zu sagen, wo die einen konstruktiven Vorschlag machen. Da war aber dann der Gauleiter in dieser Sendung, wie heißt, wie hieß die?
Also irgendeine dieser Talkrunden, äh wo er dann äh einfach mal, ich glaube von Anne Will gefragt wurde, was denn,
jetzt so, wo er jetzt die Partei sehen würde und was deren konstruktiver Beitrag in den nächsten vier Jahren,
sein würde. Was sie sich als Oppositionsarbeit, als sie setzen. Auch das ist ja für eine auch für Oppositionsarbeit brauchst du ein Konzept,
Man muss sagen so, wir werden in diese Richtung zerren. Auf jeden Fall nach den konstruktiven Beiträgen der Partei gefragt äh antwortet der Gauleiter dann, äh das wäre überhaupt nicht seine Aufgabe. Wäre überhaupt nicht unsere Aufgabe. Also sie haben im Prinzip,
dieses sage ich mal konzeptlose Geschrei ohne bessere,
Vorschläge machen zu können ohne also die beschreien ja schon den Ist-Zustand als ein unbewältigbares Problem.
Alles was ihnen dazu auf einfällt, ist äh alle Ausländer wieder raus, ne,
Musste er nach der Wahl vorsichtig zugeben, äh auch glaube ich Gauleiter, Zitat, wir werden diese Leute ja leider hier behalten müssen.
Ja? Also das ist halt sorry, das ist nicht belastbar, das ist nicht äh seriös. Solchen Leuten kannst du nicht die überhaupt die Verantwortung einer Opposition geben und du schriebst das auch in den LMP-Kommentaren sehr schön, die werden jetzt demnächst
sowas wie eine Ausschussarbeit machen müssen,
Wir haben in der letzten Legislaturperiode gesehen, wie unglaublich wichtig so eine Untersuchungsausschussarbeit ist. Mein Respekt vor den Politikern, die da den Oppositionspolitikern,
die da sichtbar ähm über ihrer Belastungsgrenze waren. Von deren äh Mitarbeitern ganz zu schweigen,
Der ist echt groß. Der ist wirklich groß. Und das ist eine, das ist eine besondere Leistung, die er verbracht haben,
Und dafür braucht man Leute mit ein bisschen Strategie, Plan, Köpfchen, Verständnis, vielleicht sogar ein abgeschlossenes Studium. Ähm das kannste äh das wir, werden wir jetzt sehen, ob die AfD da eine überzeugende politische Arbeit leisten kann.
Ja, wenn man sich halt so anschaut, wen sie bisher so in die Landtage äh geschickt haben, da wo sie reingewählt wurden, äh lässt mich das halt nicht hoffen, dass das da in irgendeiner Form äh nennenswerte äh Verstärkung in den Bundestag gekommen ist.
Das ist ja eine unabhängig von den von den inhaltlichen Differenzen halte ich das Personal auch für äh nicht seriös.
Ja, man man kann nur dankbar sein, dass die CDU wieder so viele Direktmandate gewonnen hat, aber so schlecht abgeschnitten ist
ist ja der Bundestag jetzt auf siebenhundertneun Sitze aufgebläht worden, sodass die paar Oppositionsparteien, die dann noch übrig bleiben
zumindest trotz keines äh Prozentualen zugewinnt, äh zumindest ihre Sitzzahl haben erhalten oder teilweise so glaube ich sogar ausbauen konnten,
Na ja. Mehr können wir dazu ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen
So, weil jetzt auch die jetzt befinden wir uns natürlich gerade in dieser Übergangsphase. Keiner weiß, was jetzt äh wirklich kommt, ob's jetzt irgendwie Jamaika wird oder doch nicht oder ob wir das dann noch eine Neuwahl eintreten oder doch nicht,
Äh wenn's dann mal so weit ist, dann kann man das auch mal wieder genauer ins Visier nehmen, aber aus unserer Warte heraus, denke ich mal.
Es ist spannender sich irgendwie Brexitverhandlungen anzuschauen.
Auf jeden Fall der bessere YouTube-Witz bei rumgekommen. All every one.
Ähm ja, das also Koalitionspoker kann man glaube ich besser ähm,
in anderen äh in anderen Kontexten kommentieren, ähm netzpolitisch kann man auf jeden Fall jetzt mal sagen, das ist nicht das Schlimmste ist, wenn eine CDU.
Und CSU flankiert werden von einer FDP und den Grünen. Netzpolitisch erstmal, gibt's übrigens eine sehr schöne Analyse von äh Ingo Dachwitz, ja. Der dann also sagte.
Auf Netzpolitik.
Punkt org, der dann mal sagte so,
Für die Bürgerrechte hasse mit Grünen und FDP auf jeden Fall mehr Hoffnung als mit der SPD, ja? Ähm,
FDP und Grüne erklärte Gegner von Staatstrojanern äh biometrische Überwachungen könnten die da mehr entgegenstellen als die SPD sich getraut hat. Ähm,
Datenschutz und Breitbandausbau ne sind Grüne und ähm FDP äh mutigere und treibendere Kräfte,
Insofern steht da rein netzpolitisch erstmal zu hoffen, dass die Aussichten nicht so schlecht wären,
Wenn man jetzt mal nur netzpolitisch blickt, ähm auf einer höheren Ebene betrachtet, stellt sich natürlich die Frage, ob FDP und Grüne überhaupt miteinander klarkommen wollen.
Beide Wählerlager betrachten ja den anderen als als wirklich als,
vor Spinner, findest du jetzt wenig Leute, die in ihrem Wählerverhalten zwischen FDP und Grünen,
hin und her wandern. Ähm! Die FDP steht aber in der, in der Tradition, die haben Personen wie Gerhard Baum, die haben Personen wie Sabine Leuthäuser, Schnarrenberger, in ihrer Tradition stehen, die Grünen haben Personen wie,
Hans-Christian Ströbele oder Konstantin von Nord, ähm die,
auch für 'ne, für 'ne klare digitale Position stehen wenn.
Wobei es nur Konstantin von Notz aus dieser Liste auch glaube ich tatsächlich im Bundestag vertreten ist oder ist die Leuthäuser.
Sabine Lordhäuser Schnarrenberger ist nicht vertreten, deswegen habe ich auch gesagt, in ihrer Tradition steht Gerd Baum ist über achtzig Jahre alt.
Ja, ja. Ist über achtzig Jahre alt. Nee, klar.
Klagten nur noch vorm Bundesverfassungsgericht für Bürgerrechte. Übrigens auch krass, dass äh wusste ich gar nicht, dass er so alt ist, macht einen sehr viel jüngeren Eindruck. Und ich habe den am vierundzwanzigsten September nämlich gesehen, ähm weil.
Also am Wahlabend.
Ja, weil deren Wahlparty war unweit das CC Berlin und dann liefen wir da so lang und,
dann stand er da. Ich gehe auch. Gell, Baum. Macht der denn hier an der Ecke und dann war eben klar, ja, da ist die FDP Wahlparty. Dann sind wir schnell weggerannt,
Na ja, also könnte man, man könnte eine Jamaika-Koalition vorsichtig,
mutig oder man könnte eine eine Jamaika-Koal Koalition rein, netzpolitisch vorsichtig positiv. Äh wird bewerten. Aber.
Sofern das dann nicht mit dem CSU-Innenminister garniert wird,
also ich halte mich da nochmal sehr zurück in der äh Bewertung und habe da äh nicht viele Erwartungen. Ich lasse mich aber gerne angenehm überraschen.
Wir schauen mal.
Insofern ist ja auch dieser ganze Rechtsruck, den wir jetzt irgendwie gesehen haben, noch keine abgemachte Sache, ja, also ob diese Regierung am Ende so sehr viel Rechter unterwegs sein wird, ähm was bleibt abzuwarten.
Ach so, ein, mein Lieblingstweed am Wahlabend war übrigens ähm es wäre schön, wenn die AfD ab jetzt in der medialen Berichterstattung den,
Ihnen zustehenden Anteil bekommen würde, Doppelpunkt, dreizehn Prozent. Ja, das könnte man auch echt mal sich wünschen. Ich suche für die Shownotes noch raus, von wem dieser Tweet war, den verlinken wir dann. Das wäre ja.
Also ehrlich gesagt, fände ich ja dreizehn Prozent noch ein bisschen zu viel, aber äh ein Nobert ist es going,
So oder so gab es dann aber doch für uns äh zumindest so halbwegs relevante Nachrichten rund um die Wahl zur allgemeinen Belustigung
musste Berlin ähm die Verkündigung der Wahlergebnisse in den Berliner Wahlkreisen ein wenig zurückstellen, denn man hatte Wunder, Wunder
Probleme bei der äh digitalen Schnellerfassung
was jetzt nicht, wie es ja ganz putzig gewesen wäre mit dem in diesem Format so ausführlich besprochenen PC-Wahldesaster zusammenhing, nein es war tatsächlich die
IT-Infrastruktur, die offensichtlich schwächelte, da ist die Rede von einer Cloud, äh, sagen wir mal
Da gab's so Server und äh die haben nicht näher definierte Probleme gezeigt. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob es da überhaupt einen technischen Bericht oder so.
Nicht voll belastbar. Also da gibt's sehr kryptische.
Äußerung ist auch völlig egal. Ehrlich gesagt ähm es zeigt einfach nur, dass wir,
dass nicht nur aus IT-Sicherheitsperspektive diese Durchführung der Wahl wirklich am seidenen Faden hängt. Ja, es gab also eine Reihe,
an Problemen in Berlin eben mehrere Stunden technische Probleme, gab keine Wahlergebnisse hm,
dann in Berlin unterschiedliche Darstellungen der Zwischenergebnisse,
Mhm. Also in für Charlottenburg-Wilmersdorf äh wurden beim Bundeswahlleiter und bei der Landeswahlleiterin unterschiedliche Stimmanteile angezeigt,
Ja, also,
Ähm beim äh Bundeswehrleiter wurde gesagt, Tim Renner äh Kandidat der SPD sei mit achtundzwanzig Komma acht Prozent der Gewinner. Ähm
vorläufigen amtlichen Endergebnis liegt allerdings seine CDU-Kandidat Klaus-Dieter Gröhler vorne,
Also auch da sieht man, das ist alles irgendwie nicht so ganz sauber.
Mhm.
In München war die Wahlbeteiligung über neunzig Prozent, musste dann aber äh äh korrigiert werden und dann gab's noch irgendwo eine ähm.
Quasi falsche Werte, wie viele die, wie viel die Parteien eben vergeben im Vergleich zum Vorjahr ähm
Vergleich zu der Vorwahl zu oder abgenommen hätten pro Zentual. Also da gab's 'ne Reihe skurriler Fehler und die sind alle so in dem Bereich der sich sagt diese Infrastruktur hängt einerseits am seidenen Faden und andererseits äh das größtere, das größte Risiko für Fehlergebnisse bei einer Bundestagswahl ist sowieso die krottenschlechte
Usability dieser Software insofern ähm sehe ich da alles bestätigt, was wir äh vorhergesagt haben.
Ja und vor allem, ich meine, die Kritik an der ganzen Auseinandersetzung mit PC-Wahl war ja äh auch immer so äh gelagert. Na ja, was wollt ihr denn eigentlich, dass es ja am Ende nicht entscheidend,
wir haben ja dann im Wesentlichen argumentiert, mag ja sein so, äh erstens noch,
Und zweitens, jetzt stelle man sich mal vor, man hätte halt jetzt solche äh Ausreißer deutschlandweit gehabt,
Und dann hätte man sie auch nicht innerhalb einer Stunde äh korrigiert bekommen oder zweien. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie lange sich das so hinzog, teilweise,
musst du da wahrscheinlich auch erstmal so auf den nächsten Tag gewartet werden, bis man in Ruhe was bestätigen konnte dann ist das schon nicht so ganz unentscheidend. So,
einfach auch aus dem Grund, dass irgendwann so ein Schwellwert erreicht wird, wo man dann sagt, so, ja, glauben wir euch eigentlich überhaupt noch irgendetwas, was äh mit dieser Wahl zu tun hat so? Und dann haben wir halt wieder dieses,
Problem, ne? Also das ist einfach geboten an dieser Stelle ordentlich zu arbeiten. So, ich meine äh,
Deutschland ist zurecht im Verruf, ist immer sehr genau zu nehmen,
mit allem, ja? So äh dann soll man doch doch bitte diesen Klischee dann auch weiterhin entsprechen. Es wäre sehr angemessen f.
Es war doch jetzt gerade dieser Digitalgipfel in Tallin.
Wurde an Angela Merkel äh völlig überraschend einsah, dass ähm dass Deutschland nicht der Markt für nicht der der Weltführer.
In der Digitalisierung.
Der Marktführer der Digitalisierer ist, ne?
Das hat sie jetzt erst gemer.
Ja, es war echt irre, der hat's, der hat's, aber sie hat's gemerkt.
Nein, mein.
Ich suche gerade mal den, es war so ein wunderschöner, es war ein inspirierender Tag, der gezeigt hat, dass wir noch weit von der Weltspitze entfernt sind. Kanzlerin Merkel nach dem Talent Digital Summit. Ja.
Wow.
Spannend, ne?
Netzbuch Lokpolitik gehört.
Unglaublich, dafür musst du nach Talin.
Ja, dafür muss man nach Tali fahren, ne? Ja, sorry, also das äh hättet ihr auch einfacher haben können.
Kommen wir mal zu den schlechten Nachrichten.
Genau.
Bei uns auch schon erwähnt wurde, dass im Rahmen des,
G zwanzig Gipfels in Hamburg. Äh insgesamt achtundzwanzig Journalisten ohne Angabe von Gründen vor Ort die Akkreditierung entzogen wurde. Das war dann irgendwie so quasi am Einlang, am Eingang zum Pressecenter, das es da gab, standen,
Äh gab's auf einmal eine Liste mit Namen und wenn dann da die entsprechenden Journalisten Eingang begehrten, dann wurde ihnen,
Akkreditierung der Presseausweis, da die Akkreditierung und der Ausweis, der ihnen Zugang ermöglicht weggenommen,
Und gesagt, hiermit entziehen wir in die Akkreditierung, weil sie sind gefährlich, ja? Wurde also aus Sicherheitsgründen? Hm,
Bundesregierung kommentierte dazu ja, das ist natürlich klar, ist ein Eingriff in die Pressefreiheit war aber notwendig, aus Sicherheitsgründen, weil das waren nämlich irgendwie
Linksterroristische Gewalttäter, linksversiffte, denen mussten wir ähm die Akkreditierung entziehen, dann wurde eben gesagt, ja
das haben wir ja vorher nicht geahnt, dass die, dass das so gefährlich sind und deswegen müssen sie das erst kurzfristig aufgefallen und ähm ja, aber das hat schon alles seine Richtigkeit war notwendig,
Ähm.
Gegen die Akkreditier, gegen die, gegen den Entzug der Akkreditierung haben eben, ich weiß nicht genau, ob alle, aber einige, die dieser äh Journalisten geklagt und dann hat der,
Fotograf Poming John,
ich glaube, das wird schon ausgesprochen. Ähm eine Anfrage an Landeskriminalämter und Bundeskriminaltag gestellt und hat gesagt, sag doch mal bitte hier nach,
Bundesdatenschutzauskunftsgesetz oder was auch immer. Was ihr da so über mich gespeichert habt in was für komischen Dateien,
Und dann ähm sagte das äh LKA Berlin, ja LKA Berlin. Wir haben hier ähm für zweitausend,
Fünf oder zweitausendfünfzehn so einen schweren Landfriedensbruch in der Kartei stehen und äh der äh
Dieser Fotograf oder zweitausendelf war das keine Ahnung vor ein paar Jahren, einen schweren Landfriedensbruch in den in der Datei stehen und dann sagt der Fotograf. Er kann sich gut daran erinnern, kann er ja eh, weil er ja die Fotos gemacht hat, der weiß ja dann immer, wo er da war,
sagt da wurde weder meine Personalien festgestellt, noch wurde gegen mich Anzeige erstattet und dann fragst du dich natürlich wieso ist der auf einmal in irgendeiner LKA Linksgefährder äh Datenbank als Foto als Pressefotograf, ne?
Ja und vor allem warum hat der ersten Ausweis bekommen und der wurde ihm dann erst nachdem der Gipfel schon ein paar Tage lief, erd entzogen? Also ich meine, haben sie dann ihre Datenbank erst geladen oder.
Das ist ja also das nochmal, ja, ne? Und jetzt sagt das LKA Berlin ähm also,
Jetzt hat das Eca bei den ja, wir haben das alles hier steht und dann sagen die, ja nee, wir hätten jetzt alle Datensätze gelöscht und,
'ne gute Nachricht also gibt hier nichts mehr zu sehen. So, jetzt ist natürlich krass, weil das einerseits zeigt, dass das an diesen Vorwürfen nicht dran war und da nichts dran war und dass diese Daten,
Sage ich mal nicht nachvollziehbar in dieser Kartei standen? Mit anderen Worten, dass sein sein Akkreditierungsentzug nicht.
Nicht gerechtfertigt war und auf falschen Anschuldigungen beruht. Gleichzeitig hat er aber natürlich dagegen geklagt und bei der Daten äh Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten äh eine Beschwerde eingereicht gegen diese Daten und LKA Berlin hat die jetzt gelöscht.
Also gelöscht im Sinne von gelöscht, gelöscht oder als gelöscht, markiert.
Gelöscht, gelöscht. Gelöscht, gelöscht haben wir nicht mehr.
Auch keine Backups mehr, weil wir machen generell wahrscheinlich von unseren Daten.
So, dass die nichts löschen. Aber der, also der entscheidende Punkt ist jetzt, sagt natürlich Peter Schade, er frühere Daten, äh, Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte,
Wenn Daten gelöscht werden, um zu verhindern, dass die Rechtmäßigkeit ihrer Speicherung überprüft wird, handelt es sich hier um die Unterdrückung von Beweismitteln.
Ich finde es auch so geil, dass solche Kommentare immer vom früheren Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten kommen. Was ist denn eigentlich mit der aktuellen Bundestags.
Das ist der der das ist halt der der erreichbar ist, ne? Der geht ans Telefon in das LKA Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, hat ähm irgendwo auch ähm,
ein ähm vermutlich fehlerhaften, ein Datensatz ähm gelöscht, bevor er geprüft werden konnte.
Da ging's um den äh Journalisten Chris Grodotzky, der jetzt nicht mehr erfahren wurde, wird, warum er vor Jahren ähm wegen Hausfriedensbruch in die Verbunddateien des BKA eingetragen wurde.
Das ist schon echt äh also ich meine, wir reden hier von Journalisten, ne? Müssen wir überlegen, jetzt wird der Zwitter im Fotografen ähm,
Landschwerer Lands Landfriedensbruch vorgeworfen, ne? Der schleppt doch nicht ähm paar tausend Euro Kameraequipment irgendwohin, wenn der schweren Landfriedensbruch vorhat, ne,
Verkauf dann am Ende noch oder vielleicht verkauft er sie auch nicht, weil sie keiner kauft, veröffentlicht dann nachher noch seine Pressefotos von von so einem Ding, ne.
Schwerer Land, Friedensbruch, das ist so, wenn du anfängst irgendwelche Masten umzuschmeißen.
Das halt Randale, das ist der Begriff für Randale, das ist das.
Werfen schon oder musst du schon musst du schon Elek.
Steine werfen kommst du wahrscheinlich in äh kommst du sofort Körperverletzungen und so und dann bist du ja dann wahrscheinlich auch unter diesen neuen Paragraphen, Beamten, Verletzungen oder sowas, aber schwerer Landfriedensbruch ist,
Sachbeschädigungen in der Öffentlichkeit, ne? Barrikade, Bau oder irgendwie sowas.
Oder wenn du, oder wenn du auf die Wiese vorm Bundestag gehst, das ist auch schwerer Landfriedensbruch, zumindest wenn da gerade das Zentrum für politische Schönheit überreichen. Wenn du, das ist dann wieder Körperverletz.
Wenn man Blumen überreicht so, ne? Ja ja. Ach so.
Also,
dass überhaupt Journalisten in diesen Dateien landen und jetzt ähm dann gab's eine ähm kleine Anfrage der Linken,
der dann irgendwie auch gesagt wurde, in der Praxis besteht ein uneinheitliches Meldeverfahren der Justizbehörden
sodass die Polizei teilweise keine Kenntnis von der Beendigung des Verfahrens und deren Gründen erhält und deswegen kann das halt mal sein, dass in so einer Datei drin bleibst und jetzt hier offenbar achtundzwanzig Journalisten.
Alter, vor AdWords Norden hätte es über sowas ein Aufschrei gegeben,
irgendwie mal eben achtundzwanzig Journalisten in den in den in den mehr oder weniger gegen Terrorismus und politisch motivierte Straftäter, Straftäter,
äh gerichteten Verbunddateien äh der Polizeibehörden stehen. Wahnsinn.
Die Story, die riecht auch, die riecht auch so ausm Mund. Also das ist ja auch ist das normal, ne? Also der Vorgang war ja so, die hatten ihre Akkreditierung schon,
wenn diese Einträge tatsächlich so da drin standen, dann hätten die ja niemals eine Akkreditierung bekommen dürfen.
Das ist ihnen dann halt während des Gipfels aufgefallen. Ich meine, das.
Was was so was bitte geht da ab.
Ich find's aber, also ich find's aber auch nicht, ich find's nicht besser zu sagen, man hätte denen das vorher sagen müssen. Ich finde.
Nein, aber ich meine, es macht, es macht es nochmal extra komisch, ja? Also klar, dass dass sie da dass irgendwelche Leute falsche Sachen in die Datenbank eintragen. Das ist das eine.
Zufällig bei achtundzwanzig Journalisten, überleg mal bitte, was die da noch alles in die in dieser Datenbank haben.
Ja, hab. Ja, aber haben Sie das dann während des Gipfels gemacht, dass es ihnen dann erst aufgehammelt ist, so eine Notifikation auf ihrem Telefon bekommen und so? Äh.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist ja seit Jahren da drin.
Na dann, gut, aber.
Also wie gesagt, der Skandal ist nicht, dass sie das erst nach dem Gipfel hinkriegen.
Nein, nein, das macht's nur noch unklarer, was eigentlich jetzt wirklich dazu geführt hat. So und auf welchem Level, in welcher Bedeutungsebene dieser dieser Einträge äh existierten.
Na ja. Aber die anderen Daten haben sie ja nicht äh gelöscht.
Ist er nicht der einzige Skandal beim G zwanzig, ne? Wir mit Blick auf die Uhr. Machen wir dann mal weiter. Ähm auch ein von der Öffentlichkeit,
gar nicht so viel beachtet, gab's einen hat der Kriminaldirektor Jan Hieber ähm gestern auf einer oder nein, vor mir, sorry, gestern auf Esco. Vor zwei, drei Wochen auf einer Pressekonferenz mitgeteilt. Ja, sie hätten jetzt also mehrere,
Mehrere Terrabyte an Daten.
Und man habe jetzt also bezüglich dieses G zwanzig. Man hätte jetzt Bildmaterial in einem Umfang, wie es ihnen noch nie in der deutschen Kriminalgeschichte gab,
Freut er sich, fit der histor gut, ne? Die Polizei würde jetzt, äh, hätte er, hatte er dieses Hinweisportal gestartet, das war ja auch stark, ne? Weil sie gesagt haben, ladet eure Videos bei uns hoch,
Das haben
siebentausend Dateien wurden da hochgeladen, früher hatten sie mal von zehntausend geredet, wahrscheinlich sind da einfach Duplikate rum, siebentausend Einzeldateien wurden in das
Innersten Inunziationsportal der Polizei äh hochgeladen. Auch das echt mal überraschend, ja? Ähm wenn man sich überlegt, wie.
Ähm was da, was man von sowas,
allgemein zu halten hat, ja? Also ich finde, wir wir klagen ja alle immer groß über die Stasi oder so. Ich will da auch gar keinen Stasivergleich machen, aber ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass du wirklich siebentausend Einzeldateien ähm in,
Portal der Polizei hochgeladen bekommst. Ich hätte vielleicht mit ein paar Tausend mit vielleicht mit tausend gerechnet oder so, ne? Man weiß jetzt auch nicht, wie viele Personen sich hinter diesen,
Tausenden Dateien verbergen, vielleicht sind das wenige, zehn, wenige hundert oder eben,
Wenige tausend Personen, aber ich finde schon tatsächlich erstmal überraschend, dass da so viele Hinweise eingehen,
Bei der Webseite G zwanzig Doku Punkt org, wo aufgerufen wurde, Polizeigewalt zu dokumentieren, sind ja auch viele Hinweise eingegangen, insofern,
beide Perspektiven, die um Aufklärung bemüht sind.
Haben hier Zuwachs. Die einen sagen, wir wollen Videos von Polizeigewalt haben und dokumentieren, wie die Polizei Frust an,
schuldigen, ausgelassen hat und die mit Gewalt überzogen hat, legitimer Anspruch und wenn die Polizei sagt, wir wollen Bilder von Straftätern haben, die,
Lehrerin die schweren Lehren Schwanz. Schweren Landfriedensbruch begangen haben.
Lehrer, Schwanzfriedensbruch. Ja, ja.
Die schweren Leitfriedensbruch begangen haben, dann ist das, dann treten dann ähm werden da auch Hinweise gegeben und das ist jetzt erstmal nehme ich mal nur so zur Kenntnis, ne. Das ist interessant.
Das gab's früher nicht so.
Nee, ich mein.
Ich will da auch nicht verdammen diejenigen, also vielleicht ist es also ich meine, ich kann auch um mal hier wieder Empathie zu zeigen. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass so ein vielleicht so ein friedlicher Demonstrant eben auch sagt, ey diejenigen, die uns hier unseren.
Friedfertigen, von langerhand geplanten Protest in Dreck gezogen haben.
Die denunzieren wir jetzt auch bei der Polizei. Kann auch sein. Wäre jetzt nicht mein Groove so, aber okay. Interessant ist eigentlich, deshalb ist das eine eine Meldung.
Dieses Material soll jetzt mit Gesichtserkennungssoftware durchsucht werden. Ähm dazu zu diesen siebentausend Einzeldateien kommen fünfundzwanzigtausend Einzelvideos von Polizistinnen und Polizistinnen,
die ebenfalls zu diesen Bildmassendaten kommen. Ähm das Gleiche gilt für den Inhalt von mehr als hundert Festplatten aus Bussen, Bahnen und Bahnhöfen.
Ja, also wir haben hier am Ende eine Menge an Videomaterial, die wirklich in der Form wahrscheinlich noch nie da war. Und das kippen die jetzt alles in in einen Server.
Und lass mal so ein bisschen ihre Erkennung rüberlaufen. Gesichtserkennung drüber.
Und lassen mal, lass mal Gesichtserkennung drüber rattern. Und dann werden sie unter Umständen ähm die eine oder andere Person da drin automatisch,
identifizieren können. Das ist das, wovor wir übrigens, wovon wir die ganze Zeit geredet haben
bei dem Personalausweis und Passgesetz, was ja jetzt irgendwie noch in den letzten Metern der großen Koalition erweitert wurde, wo ja dann der automatisierte Zugriff auf die biometrischen Daten ab zweitausend,
Zweiundzwanzig oder fünfundzwanzig? Erlaubt werden wird.
Das heißt, da haben wir dann, das ist also jetzt ähm euer Demonstrationserlebnis zweitausendsiebzehn. Geht hin.
Darfst keine Mütze äh oder Kapuze aufhaben, weil sonst kriegst du auf die Fresse und eine Anzeige eine Strafanzeige und dann bist du nachher in von entweder von,
Freund oder Feind oder Staat,
auf Landeshaus auf so einem Server, dann geht der Gesichtserkennungssoftware drüber und analysiert dann schön dein ähm,
dein Verhalten. Es ist unklar, welches Software da genutzt wird, aber ähm Matthias Monreu hat dabei Netzpolitik Org, das ist ja im Prinzip die Kapazität,
In Deutschland, über wenn man sich anschaut, was,
Der, der hat also das, der sammelt das Wissen darüber, welche Software, wer wo einsetzt, auf jeder Ebene und berichtet darüber und sagt, na ja, äh für Kriminalämter verkauft die Dresdner Firma Cognitec,
die Software Facebo,
VACS geschrieben, äh die auch beim Bundeskriminalamt zum Einsatz kommt, also jetzt mal ein Educate Guest und sagt, was, was sie so kann,
Ähm die wird zum Beispiel nutzt auch die Geodaten,
Und daraufhin können Videos und Fotos gesucht werden, die am gleichen Ort entstanden sind. Ja, ich erinnere mich vor vielen Jahren, ich weiß gar nicht, welche Freiheit statt Angstdemo das war, als dieser ähm junge Mann im blauen T-Shirt da von den Polizisten.
Am Potsdamer Platz.
Verkloppt wurde so, da gab's dann am Ende vom Chaos Computerclub, glaube ich, wurde das äh veröffentlicht, dann so ein YouTube-Video, wo alle Aufnahmen, die man hatte,
die im,
In dem Zusammenhang waren parallel in ein Video gemacht wurden. Das wurde halt quasi von Hand synchronisiert ne und dann saß du die gleiche Situation aus mehreren Videos gleichzeitig. Das war ähm eine riesen manuelle Arbeit, ne? Damals noch.
Gab's jetzt auch Jüngst bei diesem äh Überfall dieser türkischen Sicherheitsleute da in USA auf äh Demonstranten gab's dann auch entsprechende Aufbereitungen. Na ja.
Das machst du heute automatisch. Kannst du am gleichen Ort sehen und wenn das jetzt mit der ähm,
Wenn das jetzt mit der Gesichtserkennung,
Kombiniert wird, dann kann's nämlich im, dann klickst du nachher auf so ein, auf so einen Menschen und dann hast du quasi eine Menschensuche und kannst sagen, wo habe ich denn noch alles in Videos,
Oder eben gehst auf den Ort und sagst, was habe ich noch für Videos von diesem Ort,
Das ist da landen die Daten, wenn man jetzt also Hinweise bietet. Und das ist schon echt ähm.
Ja, das ist äh ausreichend Scary, also man muss sich halt mal klar machen, wie viel also ne, wir haben.
Das ist diese Videotechnik, die uns die CD.
Das ist sich genau, das ist die Videotechnik und ähm,
Das klingt jetzt so alles so einzeln für sich ne, mag das vielleicht noch gar nicht so einen erregen, aber es ist halt die Kombination aus wo,
wann und wer. Und wenn man das irgendwie dann so massenhaft macht und hier auch noch mit Terabyte prallt, ja, was vielleicht jetzt auch mal gar nicht mal so viel ist. Äh wir wissen jetzt nicht, wie viele Terabyes oder war das,
genannt. Nee, ne? Tirabat war nur so ein Schlagwort, ne? Oder gab's eine konkretere Zahl.
Teearbeit ist jetzt gerade irgendwie das Synonym für eine Menge. So und wenn man halt jetzt von tausenden Leuten und Prinzip,
spätestens dann mit dem Zugriff auf die Fotos, auf dem Personalausweis ist das da ja dann sozusagen auch gegeben, ne? Und quasi so genauso viele Daten hat wie Facebook und man weiß halt, wer ist wer und dann,
ist es einfach gar kein Thema mehr. Man kann mit einer HD-Kamera heute auf eine Menschenmenge draufhalten, da gab's ja die noch vor ein paar Tagen auch nochmal so ein, so ein äh automatisches Ticking-Video von den Chinesen irgendwie rum, wo das äh
auch schön zu sehen war, ja, wie mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit von der Kamera eben Leute erkannt werden. Und das ist,
das ist jetzt leider kein Zukunftsszenario mehr. Und du kannst ja auch mehr rauslesen, du kannst wie gucken die, ja, wie fühlen die sich gerade? Das ist äh alles äh machbar,
und dann hast du halt 'ne sehr umfangreiche Datenbank, wer ist mit wem, wann, wo langgegangen.
Jetzt kombinierst du das noch mit ähm vom Zellenabfragen, dann sparst du dir nämlich durch potenziell achtzig Millionen Bilder zu suchen, sondern,
Such's halt einfach erstmal nur durch die durch die Individuen, die laut ihrer,
Laut einer Funkzellenabfrage zu dem Zeitpunkt an dem Ort waren.
Du weißt nicht, ob es so nennt, warum muss man es darauf beschränken? Ich meine.
Nee, beschränkst du nicht, aber dann dann läuft's natürlich schneller, ne? Das heißt, du guckst, du du suchst die, durchsuchst die natürlich priorisiert.
Gut, aber du kannst ja einfach alle machen.
Kannst du auch alle machen? Ich sage, ich sage nur, wie du so wie du den Prozess jetzt so ein bisschen noch ähm noch vielleicht.
Daten bereicherst, um dann am Ende zu sagen, sag mal vielleicht kannst du am Ende zwischen zwei Gesichter nicht unterscheiden, dann hast du noch Ausschlussverfahren, je mehr Daten du dazu hast, desto besser wird das und dann sind wir einfach an dem Punkt,
Sehr bald,
dass du bei so einer Demonstration wirklich einfach erfasst wirst, fertig. Und zwar zu hundert Prozent, entweder durch dein Gesicht oder durch dein Handy.
Wenn ich nur erfasst wird, sollen vor allem auch in Kombulation gesetzt wird. Und ich meine, wir sehen ja auch gerade, wie äh wieso das Verhältnis zu, wann mal was speichert und wann man was löscht äh ist, ja,
kann durchaus davon ausgehen, dass diese Daten dann auch noch länger länger rumliegen und auch Gesichter, die heute nicht erkannt werden, können ja dann vielleicht in zwei Monaten, drei Jahren oder zehn Jahren äh auch noch zugeordnet werden,
und dann packt man halt die alten Daten mal wieder aus, ne? So, ja, aber sie waren doch schon vor ein paar Jahren schon auf den G zwanzig Demonstrationen.
Jetzt wollen sie hier Lehrer werden.
Ja, ja,
guter, sehr guter Punkt, ja? Also äh genau das ist das, ja und das ist auch so ein bisschen der Kern, warum wir das
so kritisiert, ne? Klar, man kann natürlich sagen, na ja, aber damit Straftaten stattgefunden haben und so weiter und so weiter. Ja klar, meinetwegen,
Problem ist nur, wir werden diesen ganzen Scheiß halt einfach nicht mehr los. Und irgendwann ist das halt mehr als die Auskunft und die Ermittlungen
einer einzigen Straftat und wir bewegen uns halt langsam, aber sehr beständig auf so eine Situation hin, in der halt
jeder in jedem Kontext in irgendeiner Form abgespeichert wird. Ich meine, die Handydaten sind da heute schon,
Schon sehr krass. Und Video liegt dem Ganzen sozusagen nochmal nochmal so eine Sahneschicht äh oben drauf.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung hast du auch noch.
Ja so es ne es akumuliert sich einfach durch jede dieser einzelnen Maßnahmen,
da können wir echt nochmal von Glück sagen, dass wir hier in Deutschland überhaupt eine Gesetzgebung haben, die sich mit diesem Thema auseinandersetz,
im Gegensatz zu anderen Ländern, wo einfach nur fröhliches Scheiß drauf herrscht. Na ja.
Ich finde, also dass.
Was man bei diesen Sachen immer wieder betrachten muss ist, die zoomen sich ja den richtigen Moment, ne? Die die allgemeine Stimmung,
Ist jetzt irgendwie so ja diese G zwanzig Gewalttäter und so weiter, ne.
Die bösen Linken.
Die bösen Linken, es hat sich, glaube ich, so, es gab einige Nachfragen und das Thema hat sich auch, sage ich mal, in der interessierten Öffentlichkeit auch mal gehalten, mal zu fragen so inwiefern hat,
Polizei hier versagt oder bewusst eskaliert
Wir hatten da ja auch eine Sendung zu. Auch die sehr äh emotional kommentiert. Ähm.
Unabhängig davon, wie man jetzt grundsätzlich zu der Legitimität der Proteste steht. Ähm unabhängig davon ähm wie man dazu steht, dass es hier um die Verfolgung von,
von, dass es hier noch nur um die Verfolgung von Straftätern geht, ja? Und dass dann auch vielleicht einige sagen, ja, ihr könnt doch ruhig meine Gesichter erfassen. Ähm, es ist jetzt und dann könnt ihr wenigstens feststellen, dass ich ähm,
unschuldig bin, ja? Also es wird ja vielleicht auch immer davon ausgegangen, dass solche Daten genutzt werden, zu, dass da mal eine Entlastung stattfinden könnte,
Aber die für die Idee, dass wir kommen, wenn mal schlechtere Zeiten kommen.
Echt keinen Staat haben wollen, der diese Techniken hat,
Ist das alles kein ähm ist das alles keine Entschuldigung. Und deswegen ist das so schwierig ähm,
An dieser Stelle dagegen zu argumentieren und hier mal aus einer Perspektive, wie soll es in ein paar Jahren sein, dadrauf zu blicken? Und wenn, solange solche Themen immer am konkreten Einzelfall diskutiert werden.
Und am Ende dann irgendwie, hey, der Linus äh sympathisiert hier mit den Gewalttätern, der will, dass die gedeckt bleiben oder was auch immer, ja?
Nee, darum geht's hier nicht. Es geht darum, das ist jetzt hier einmal G zwanzig und in zehn Jahren ist das Standard,
Und dann kannst, dann nimmst du an keiner Demonstration mehr teil, ohne dass du das automatisch erfasst wird. Und dann ist es einfach da. Fertig.
Und dann kannst du sagen, toll, dass wir damals in Hamburg äh den Typen erwischt haben, der einen Stein geworfen hat, der fahrt jetzt echt wert.
Ja, wann sind die Landtagswahlen in Sachsen? Also zehn Jahre, weiß ich gar nicht, ob wir jetzt schon soweit nach vorne blicken müssen.
Schön.
Schöne neue Welt.
Schöne neue Welt haben wir da.
Nochmal gut, dass zumindest irgendwie im Internet noch alles in Ordnung ist.
Genau, im Internet ist alles in Ordnung. Wir haben ja zum Glück,
So einen ausführlichen Kampf für die Netzneutralität auf EU-Ebene geführt und jahrelang da äh,
da daran gesessen und können da jetzt Erfolge feiern. Feine Sache, ja? Und am besten ist ja eigentlich, dass sich auch gezeigt hat
die Horrorszenarien, die da immer von den Netzfundamentalisten gezeigt wurden, ne, dass sie mal wieder absolut überzogen waren. Was haben wir damals gezeigt mit äh äh ne, also was für eine Witzvorstellung
ja? Äh ich erinnere mich noch. Er war dann so ähm wurde dann so gezeigt äh,
buchen Sie hier für Video, buchen Sie hier für Audio,
WhatsApp ist leider nicht in ihrem Programm, aber sie können hier den den Pass für für WhatsApp mieten. Dann haben sie einen Monat WhatsApp. Das haben wir darüber gelacht, ey. Das war ja sowas von äh von eine hysterische Panikmache, dieser Netzfundamentalisten wieder, ne? Schlimm,
Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm.
Das Problem ist, dass Marketing äh unsere Sendung hört und sich denkt, eigentlich eine geile Idee.
Ja, Vodafone macht jetzt genau das. Also das, was immer.
Von Anfang an als wir hingegangen sind und gesagt haben, Netzneutralität muss bleiben, tut das nicht, was ihr da vorhabt. Verbietet das, es muss verboten werden. Sonst machen die das nämlich.
Wurde immer gesagt, ja Panik, hysterische Panikmacher. Jetzt können die Vodafone-Kunden in den Tarifen Red und Young,
Bis zu vier verschiedene Pässe abonnieren, etwa für Videomusik, für Chats oder für die Nutzung sozialer Netzwerke.
Wenn man den Vertrag abschließt, ist ein Pass kostenlos enthalten, kannste wählen. A möchtest du Chat, Musik oder Video.
Und wenn du einen weiteren Pass haben möchtest, je nachdem kostet der fünf Euro, wenn ein Video beinhaltet, kostet zehn Euro,
Und die ersten Partner-Apps sind Facebook Messenger, Telegram, Threema, WhatsApp, Facebook, Instagram, Pinterist, Twitter, Amazon Music, irgendwas kenne ich gar nicht, Dezer,
dieser Netznepster, Nepster gibt's auch noch. Äh SoundCloud, Amazon Prime,
Äh äh also Amazon Prime Video, Netflix, Sky Go und Vivo,
Weitere sollen folgen mit anderen Worten, weitere erstmal nicht? Wer also die nutzen möchte, der darf schön teures, echtes Datenvolumen kaufen, wo du, wo du richtig einfach, wo völlig egal ist, wo das hingeht,
Das ist teures, teures Geld, das kann man nicht einfach kriegen. Einfach Datenvolumen, wo du, wo du selber entscheidest, wohin das geht. Nee, nee, das geht nicht.
Schickt mir doch mal ein Video über Single. Ah nee, kann ich mir nicht leisten irgendwie. Ich habe nur zwei Gigabyte und mal lieber was anderes.
Messenger muss sich wieder lohnen.
Ja
ne? Wäre natürlich wieder alles überhaupt gar kein Problem, hätten wir kein ähm ja hätten wir nicht so eine prekäre Datenvolumensituation in Deutschland,
ja? Weil wozu soll man irgendwas in Pässe einteilen und irgendwie aus Volumina rausrechnen, wenn diese Volumina sowieso so groß sind, dass ich darüber keine Gedanken mache, weil ne,
Ist ja nicht so, dass das jetzt unmöglich wäre, machen ja auch die anderen Länder so.
Reinhard äh sagte das sehr schön. Ähm ganz klar am Anfang des Monats ist ja hat das Netz ja noch Volumen. Zum Ende des Monats geht das.
Die geht in die Puste aus.
Geht dem Netz die Puste aus. Deswegen muss man das begrenzen.
Ja, die Switcher, die sind einfach dann auch äh Ende des Monats schwierig.
Da sind die, da muss der Switch gegossen werden.
Ja Neumond und was alles mit reinkommt.
Müssen neue Bits rein. Die Bits sind ja alle weg. Alle wollen Bits. Keiner fragt sich, wo die herkommen sollen.
Bittknappheit in Deutschland.
Bittbit-Knapphei.
Aber chronisch.
Chronische Bitknappheit, ja.
Knappheit in Deutschland und deswegen ist halt äh,
so ein karitativ aufgestelltes Unternehmen wie Vodafone leider gezwungen. Hier äh entsprechende Essensmarken rauszugeben, ja? Nichts anderes ist das und ähm.
Man kann nur hoffen, dass es genauso wie dieser Stream-Ohren-Blödsinn der Telekom demnächst mit entsprechenden Entscheidungen fällt, aber dass die Politik hier mal äh sagt, sag mal Leute, geht's noch? Sehen wir natürlich auch nicht,
Und warum nicht? Nicht, weil wir jetzt gerade Regierungsbildung haben, sondern weil das ist ja so kompliziert zu verstehen,
versteht ja China. Frau Merkel hat ja jetzt gerade erst erfahren, dass Deutschland gar nicht so gut dasteht, ja? Also zufällig, weil was hätten wir gemacht.
Mal nach Talent gefahren ist.
Was hätten wir gemacht, wenn sie in Urlaub woanders gemacht hätte, ja, dann hätte es bis heute noch nicht gemerkt.
Da auch da hätte sie auf einer Busfahrt über LTE Netflix gucken können. Während sie durch was weiß ich.
Ja. Zieh durch. Nicht nur im Detflix. Hältst du auf Media CD, sieht man die ganzen Vorträge anschauen können. Ja. Ohne Pass.
Es ist wirklich äh also da da müssen wir jetzt hoffen, dass äh die Bundesnetzagentur mal aus dem Kniff kommt.
Und da mal geltendes Recht umsetzt, denn es kann ja nicht sein, ne? Also wir sagen ja immer das Recht muss besser organisiert sein als das Verbrechen,
Hier wäre mal ein Fall. Hier könnte man mal gegen die organisierte Kriminalität vorgehen. Ja. Ähm aber nein nein, da wird natürlich weggeschaut.
Überhaupt die, also die Netzsituation in Deutschland, ich bin ja,
Weiß ich nicht. Ich ich leide ja, ich muss das jetzt einfach mal hier erzählen. Ich bin ja äh autogeschädigter, ne? Ich bin im Opfernetz. Ähm,
Ich habe am laufenden Band Gesprächsabbrüche, ich habe nie Daten, ich fühle mich, als wäre ich irgendwo,
In der Wüste unterwegs, aber und sobald ich irgendwo mal in der Wüste bin, dann merke ich das meistens daran, dass ich vernünftige Daten habe, weil's in Deutschland keine Wüsten gibt. Also, wenn ich in der Wüste bin, bin ich irgendwo anders und da funktioniert auf auf einmal auch Internet.
Aber die Preise, die in Deutschland gelten,
Wende dir jetzt mal, also wenn du mal jetzt in es gibt halt nur ein Netz, was in Deutschland in der Lage ist, zumindest das zu liefern, was es, was es verspricht, nämlich eine Verbindung.
Die Preise sind hier wahnsinnig.
Der zu heulen. Also ich kann auch nicht wechseln, das ist einfach unmöglich, ein Tarif zu.
Also der Tarif, den ich da.
Abdeckt, was ich vorher brauche.
Der der siebzig Euro Tarif der deutschen Telekom ist für mich nicht ausreichend. Ich müsste also in diesen einhundert oder einhundertzwanzig Euro Tarif gehen, um sage ich mal das zu haben, wo wo ich sagen würde,
Jetzt fühle ich mich wenigstens so, als wäre zweitausendsiebzehn. So, also dass ich so sage so.
Oder Finnland.
Nicht, nicht, dass ich mich so fühle, als würde ich sagen,
Zukunft, ne? Also mein Wunsch ist ja eigentlich, ich möchte mein Gerät in die Hand nehmen und sagen, geil, Zukunft heute schon, ne? Aber das wäre jetzt sowas so, der der teuerste Tarif der deutschen Telekom wäre etwas, wo ich sagen würde, so.
Gegenwart, wenn ich mein Gerät in die Hand nehme und sage, ist zwar noch nicht Zukunft, aber für.
Mehr vorgestern.
Gegenwart schon mal okay, wenigstens nicht mehr gestern,
es ist es ist ein Skandal, es ist ein Skandal wie wir haben am am am ausgestreckten Arm verhungern,
und ähm es ist überall für verbrieft und klar und dokumentiert, dass die Leistung in Deutschland die schlechteste ist und die Preise, die Höchsten.
Woher das Buch kommt? Tja.
Vorher könnte das kommen. Ich weiß es auch nicht. Also ich ich habe festgestellt, jetzt die die Nobelpreise wurden ja gerade wieder vergeben,
und,
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass äh das jetzt übrigens ein krasser Themenwechsel. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass die deutsche Telekom sich da mit ihrer physikalischen Forschung über Jahrzehnte in ähm,
Abseits manövriert hat. Es war die große Hoffnung, dass die Licht durch Kupfertechnologie.
Dann irgendwann alles übernimmt.
Dann irgendwann alles übernimmt, aber auf Deibel komm raus, die kriegen kein Licht durch Kupfer gepresst, das heißt, das hat sich als physikalische Sackgasse herausgestellt, völlig überraschend.
Und jetzt sind wir mit dem, mit einer Fire to the Home Quote in Deutschland von unter einem Prozent.
Und ähm sehen, sehen blöd aus, ne? Gucken doof.
Deutsche Teekorn hat sich verzockt. Sieht andere diese lokalen Netzbetreiber kriegen das hin, ne?
Die eigentliche Nachricht ist hier der Artikel bei verlinkt, kommt von der Wirtschaft.
Wirtschaftswoche hatte, glaube ich, dass da dass da jetzt der ähm Herr Van Damm gehen musste, ne.
Genau, also die haben jetzt irgendwie bei der Telekom dann auch mal gemerkt, dass das irgendwie äh wohl alles nicht so gut läuft und äh ziehen jetzt endlich mal erste Konsequenzen.
Breitband ist noch nicht auf Zielkurs, räumt das Unternehmen in einer Bilanzanalyse ein. Ja. Tja, schade, aber ihr aber wenigstens merken sie es jetzt langsam. Zweitausendsiebzehn.
Na sie verlieren halt jetzt extrem, ich meine, das ist ja insofern auch schon mal sehr äh beruhigend, ne, dass in den Städten, in denen es halt äh einen brauchbaren Wettbewerb gibt,
Köln,
Hannover München, glaube ich, also überall wo es so starke, regionale Anbieter gibt, die ja auch schon seit längerem operieren, Emnetz und so weiter, die sind ja alle nicht neu, sondern die probieren im Prinzip seit zehn, fünfzehn Jahren
in dem Bereich voranzukommen und haben offensichtlich deutlich zukunftssicherer geplant und jetzt,
Scheitert halt überraschenderweise äh diese Methodik, die halt im Prinzip immer so äh,
Darauf setzt mit na ja, wir haben doch jetzt hier irgendwie unsere Infrastruktur, ne? Das Kupfer, das melken wir jetzt mal so lange,
wie wir müssen, bloß das Füttern halt, das ist so ein bisschen wie auch mit der deutschen Automobilindustrie, mit ihrem Diesel, ne,
So, den wollten sie jetzt auch noch solange melken und dachten, naja, das kann jetzt irgendwie ja, das hält ja noch, ne? Und irgendwann mal müssen wir vielleicht bei dem Elektrospielchen mitspielen und jetzt merken sie, dass es ihnen halt allen Fronten schadet, weil irgendwie ihr Image dahin ist und
andere Probleme dann sicherlich auch schnell hinterher kommen werden und das ist einfach alles so beunruhigend, dass dass,
diesem Land offensichtlich ein wenig die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit abhanden gekommen ist, was so zukunftstechnologien angeht.
Und das wird in den nächsten Jahren nur noch schlimmer werden, ne? Also das wird dann sitzen sie hier bei ihren Startup Messen und sagen oh,
Nirgendwo gibt's so viele Startups wie in Berlin. Ja geil, schön. Ich habe aber auch von keinem gehört, aus dem hier jemals was geworden ist, ne? Also man könnte irgendwie.
Zum Beispiel.
Soundchot ist gerade kurz vor der Pleite. Die haben gerade, die haben.
Die jetzt.
Eingestellt, so ungefähr.
Jetzt zu sagen, dass.
Gut, das waren dann werden wir irgendwann sagen, werden wir alles sagen, es war nicht alles schlecht im Start-up Deutschland, immerhin hatten wir damals große Hoffnungen in ein Musikstreaming-Dienst. Ja, also im Meer ist doch da, sorry.
Na gut, äh dass sie Streaming nicht gemacht haben, das ist ja eher ihr Problem. Also,
Davon unabhängig, ich will nur nicht pauschal sagen, dass jetzt hier alles äh vor die Hunde geht und sicherlich im kleinen und feinen ist was da, aber da ist halt noch kein größerer Trend abzureiten äh, ne, aber wenn man.
Infrastruktur brauchst du Visionen für die Zukunft. Seit zehn Jahren ruhen sich die deutschen Automobilhersteller darauf aus, dass es keine Ladestationen gibt, deswegen bauen sie keine Elektroautos ähm und seit zehn Jahren rührt sich die deutsche Telekom darauf aus, ähm,
dass es keine Glasfaser gibt, deswegen legen sie keine. Das so geht das nicht. Märkte,
für die Zukunft müssen erschlossen werden und dafür braucht man Investitionen und diese großen Techgiganten,
Die gerade hier diese Welt dominieren, die haben nicht
Deshalb die Größe erlangt, weil sie eine Marktanalyse gemacht haben und gesagt haben, wo, wo, wo besteht denn gerade Nachfrage? Sondern weil sie
Dinge geschaffen haben, die geil waren, die dann äh die eine Nachfrage gefunden haben.
Elektrisches Auto ähm hier Smartphone ähm online Shopping,
Hat am hätte dir je zu jedem Zeitpunkt, wo die Leute da massiv reininvestiert haben mit Mut? Da hätte denen jeder gesagt, das kauft euch heute keiner ab. Ja, stimmt.
Aber morgen. Huh, was? Echt? Sorry.
Wobei mir ehrlich gesagt jetzt der individuelle Erfolg eines einzelnen Unternehmens an der Stelle eigentlich schon jetzt egal ist. Ich meine der der Misserfolg der Telekom, der jetzt hier in diesem Bericht äh beklagt wird, ist ja wiederum zum Vorteil anderer Unternehmen und das ist ja insofern auch in Ordnung. Nur
was mich am meisten stört ist, dass halt der komplette Standort darunter leide.
Genau, genau, das ist der P.
Du hast halt einfach äh Unternehmen, die damit gar nichts zu tun haben. Ich meine äh was weiß ich, du bist jetzt irgendwo in Brandenburg,
Machst du irgendwie einen Laden auf? Hast du irgendwie eine eine interessante Dienstleistung ausgedacht? Merkst irgendwann so, na ja, also ohne Onlineshop und,
Po und irgendwie richtigen Support und so und dann stehst du da und gehst zur Telekom und sagst ja guten Tag, wie ist denn das mit Internetnahe, also zwei Megabit können sie sofort haben, aber in den nächsten drei Jahren haben wir
auf sechs. So und dann zeigst du den Vogel und sagst irgendwie was geht, ne?
Und das ist die wirtschaftliche, das ist die das tötet Wirtschaft, das tötet Wirtschaft und gerade jetzt sagst du in Brandenburg auf dem Land.
Ja hier auch in der Mitteebene. Ich sitze hier auch schon seit Jahren irgendwie mit derselben Geschwindigkeit fest, ich kann hier nicht äh hoskalieren. Ich hätte, ich hätte schon im Prinzip einen halben Markt übernommen,
Ja, also würde doch gar keiner mehr von was anderem reden, aber ich äh kriege ja hier kein meine Bits nicht in die Welt.
Stell dir das mal, was das für, was das für einen Mittelstand äh der nicht in einem Betrieb in Metropole wohnt, bedeutet, das ist nicht.
Ja, das ist Stand, uns ist ein Standortproblem und sind dann nicht äh ich meine, das Unternehmen hätte dann immer noch die Möglichkeit, woanders hinzugehen. Aber das führt halt dazu, dass eben diese
ganze Problematik mit in auf den Ländern ist nichts also auf dem auf dem Dorf ist nix los ja da da tut sich wirtschaftlich nichts, da hast du dann keine keine Jobmaschinen, weil sich einfach da einfach auch niemand ansiede
wollen würde, ja? Meine, man
Viele äh mögen ja so mit diesem, na ja, Gott Stadt ist ja dann auch anstrengend, vielleicht wohne ich ja mal woanders, aber dann wohnen sie halt alle nur da und fahren dann irgendwie mit der S-Bahn oder mit ihrem SUV äh nach Berlin, weil sie nur in der Metropole überhaupt in der Lage sind,
ein Unternehmen zu betreiben oder auch eben auch nur eine Selbstständigkeit ordentlich
durchzuziehen, weil die einfach dort vor Ort gar nicht machbar ist so und dann hast du eben diese Asymmetrie, äh die sich dann halt im Verkehr und äh im Gewerbesteueraufkommen et cetera äh niederschlägt und äh langfristig natürlich dann für die Region auch nicht besser ist.
Und 'ne perspektivlose Menschen die abgeschnitten sind von von YouTube, von dem was Welt und Zukunft bedeutet ja?
Was Bildung auch betrifft.
Sehr schöne, warum ich das denn gesehen ich glaub das war.
Da kommt, dann kommt die Telekom und erzählt einem mir, wieso was wollt ihr denn mit eurem Tarif? Ihr könnt doch zwei Filme pro Monat gucken.
Ja, der Hammer. Aber dass man irgendwie vielleicht mal rund um die Uhr irgendwie HD Streams äh zu seinen Kooperations äh Partnern laufen lassen möchte auf so eine Idee kommen ja gar nicht. Heulen.
Was mit diesem Internet wird sich auch nicht durchsetzen. Das wird sich äh das wird sich, also ich sage dir Tim, die Zukunft ist Kohleenergie und Dieselmotoren. Da sind wir, das wird richtig nochmal, da wird nochmal ein richtiger Boom kommen.
Und alle Studien belegen das.
Wir haben uns das in der Vergangenheit angeschaut.
Alle Studien sagen das Gleiche, das kann sich alles äh nicht durchsetzen, da ist nichts veröffentlicht worden. Aus dem irgendein anderes Weltbild sich ableiten ließe.
Womit wir bei den Kurzmeldungen wären, Studien,
Studien sind ja ganz spannend, ne? Also Studien? Ich habe jetzt eine Studie so ein gespaltenes Verhältnis. Die Frage bei einer Studie ist, gibst du muss immer auf den Auftraggeber schauen. Wollte der Auftraggeber,
hatte der Genuines Interesse und wollte was lernen, wie zum Beispiel,
Kato, der Kai Theodor von Nutzung Gutenberg, der wollte was lernen, weil der promovieren wollte, ne. Deswegen hat er den wissenschaftlichen Dienst des deutschen Bundestages Fragen gestellt. Der hat die beantwortet, der Gutenberg hat die,
Mit auf achtzig Disketten gespeichert, am Ende gesagt, dass meine Doktorarbeit, dann habe ich jetzt rausgefunden. Der hatte, das war ein Forscher,
Das war jemand, der wollte Dinge lernen.
Ja, sehr kreativ.
Dann gibt es äh dann gibt es manchmal Leute, die brauchen eine Studie, um ähm,
Um ein politisches Handeln irgendeiner Form zu rechtfertigen. Da ist der Auftraggeber dann im Prinzip jemand, der sagt,
Der sagt, ich könnte dir mal bitte folgendes erforschen, sondern der sagt, könntet ihr mal bitte folgenden Sachverhalt herausfinden.
Könntet ihr mal bitte eine Studie schreiben, bei der rauskommt Folgendes. Und da hat die EU-Kommission im Jahr zweitausenddreizehn eine Pirateriestudie ausgeschrieben und hat gesagt, wir würden gerne ähm wissen
Ähm,
wie die Verdrängungseffekte sind zwischen illegalen und legalen Angeboten. Also verdrängen die illegalen Angebote, legale Angebote und haben wir deswegen das Recht so massiv gegen illegale Angebote vorzugehen, weil sie ein Wirtschaftshemmnis sind.
Und dann sind die Forscher hingegangen, haben gesagt, ja okay, versuchen wir mal rauszufinden. Zentrales Ergebnis, nein,
Es gibt keine statistisch nachweisbaren Verdrängungseffekte, illegale Angebote verdrängen legale Angebote nicht,
Da hat die E-Kommission gesagt, ja okay, scheiße, das passt irgendwie nicht zu unserer Politik. Danke für die Studie. Wir legen die mal hier in diese Schublade. Woraufhin Julia Reder,
EU-Abgeordnete, Piratenpartei, bei uns auch schon bei der hundertfünfzigsten zur Sendung zu Gast gewesen. Letzte letzte Bastion ähm.
Zeig mal die Studie,
Und jetzt kommt sie raus und dann stellt sich äh stellt sich raus, dass diese, dass die EU-Kommission, diese Studie einfach mal zwei Jahre lang vor der Öffentlichkeit versteckt hat, weil sie lieber ihre Politik wieder besseren Wissens weiterführen wollte.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch herzlichen Glückwunsch dafür, vielen Dank. Schön, dass wir solche EU-Kommissare haben. Haben wir auch die besten Leute hingeschickt.
Ötzinger.
Der Generalbundesanwalt hat äh die NSA-Affäre jetzt auch für beendet äh äh erklärt, ja und schreibt ähm,
Schreibt ein schönes, schönen Brief und sagt ja hier übrigens wir haben, ich habe mir das jetzt mal alles angeschaut. Das war die Strafanzeige.
Wegen des Verdachts der nachrichtendienstlichen Ausspähungen von Daten durch den amerikanischen äh militärischen Nachrichtendienst NSA und den britischen Nachrichtendienst äh GCH. Lalalala. Ich habe mir das jetzt mal alles angeschaut
Die in den Medienberichten dargestellten Ausspielungsversuche der vergangenen Nachrichten der vorgenannten Nachrichtendienste beruhen im Wesentlichen auf den Angaben des früheren externen technischen Mitarbeiters der NSA Edword Snowden,
Die bislang veröffentlichen Dokumente schildern allgemein die Möglichkeiten und Maßnahmen äh konkrete Sachverhalte,
mit Bezug zu Deutschland und der deutschen Staatsgehör gehöre ich und und deutschen Staatsangehörigkeiten enthalten die Dokumente nicht. Deswegen,
Zum Zwecke der Prüfung der Plausibilität,
haben wir uns das mal angeschaut und kommen nach vier Seiten äh äh zu dem Ergebnis, nach drei Seiten.
Nach derzeitigen Erkenntnisstand ist es daher nicht möglich, über bloß gedankliche Möglichkeiten und Schlussfolgerungen hinaus, die für einen Anfangsverdacht einer strafbaren Handlung im Sinne des Paragraphen hundertzweiundfünfzig Absatz zwei
STPO notwendige tatsächliche Grundlage zu beschreiben,
Die Einleitung eines förmlichen Ermittlungsverfahren ist daher von gesetzeswegen zu unterbleiben. Mit freundlichen Grüßen im Auftrag Hegmann. Dieser Text wurde mit Hilfe elektronischer Einrichtung erstellt. Die Unterschrift fehlt daher,
Danke.
So viel dazu gibt keinen Anfangsverdacht für Massenüberwachung durch GCH ähm oder NSA in Deutschland. Vier Jahre lang geprüft.
Gibt's nichts zu sagen.
Ist halt jetzt so.
Ist so.
Das ist echt so diskordisch dieser Brief.
Okay. Also auf den SA Untersuchungsausschuss wird natürlich auch Bezug genommen. Wunderbar.
In Großbritannien, wo wir gerade beim GCHQ waren äh wurde jetzt ein wurde jetzt jemand,
verurteilt, weil er sich geweigert hat, der Polizei seine Passwörter zu übergeben. Geil, ne?
Das ist ja auch, ich meine, wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn die Leute irgendwie ihre eigene Privatsphäre äh schützen wollen.
Zwölf Monate auf Bewährung und sechshundertzwanzig Pfundgeldstrafe.
Ja, besonders delikat, weil das auch noch ein Mitglied einer Menschenrechtsgruppe äh war, Cage, das sind so islamische Menschen äh Rechtler,
Ja und da wollten die halt einfach mal auf den Rechner schauen, obwohl er gesagt hat, so, ne, könnt ihr vergessen und nicht bereit waren, ein Passwort herauszugeben, ist er jetzt quasi vorbestraft,
wäre er schon irgendwie vorbestraft, wäre er jetzt im Knast? Die sechshundertzwanzig Pfund kann wahrscheinlich noch das geringste Problem, aber auch das ist so eine Sache, wo man vor einiger Zeit noch geglaubt hat, so äh,
Das soll jetzt irgendwie eine Straftat sein, dass man sozusagen seine eigenen, ja, das so ein bisschen mit, zeig mir mal dein Tagebuch, so ich gebe dir den Schlüssel nicht, um den aufzumachen, ja?
Sorry, aber in den Knast.
Also Cage ist eine, die äh untersuchen Menschenrechtsverletzungen im Rahmen des Kriegs gegen den Terror. Und sind da selber äh immer wieder ähm massiver,
Repression ausgesetzt und ähm ja zum Beispiel sowas.
Zum Beispiel sowas.
Damit wären wir und der Tim greift schon sehr nervös zu seinem Soundboard,
bei den Terminen.
Heute leider aufgrund der späten Sendung etwas kurzfristig kündigen wir an im fünf, am fünften Oktober um achtzehn Uhr in der Grundbuchhalle des Landgerichts Hamburg
Die Veranstaltung Happy Birthday, hamburgisches Transparenzgesetz, ein Abend mit Rück und Ausblick
auf die Entfaltung der Wirkung dieses Gesetzes, dass es inzwischen seit fünf,
Jahren gibt. Das Ganze findet statt am Sieveking Platz eins in Hamburg.
Und wenn man auch in Flensburg noch nichts weiter vorhat, dann könnte sich äh zwischen dem dritten und fünften November die Gelegenheit geben, am Weekend Hack teilzunehmen
dort soll ein Wochenende äh fleißig gehackt und äh Projekte fertig gemacht werden. Wer also für solche Aktivitäten Lust verspürt,
könnte dort auflaufen. Im Technologiezentrum in Flensburg.
Unter Weekend Hack DE gibt's neue weitere Infos muss man auch glaube ich äh sich für anmelden.
Äh ist das so? Okay, ne dann.
Ticket glaube ich kaufen. Weil gibt Essen und am Sonntag ein Frühstück und so für für leibliches Wohl ist gesorgt und deswegen wird gibt's da auch ein Ticketverkauf.
Ja, dann bleibt uns äh nur noch bis Ende der Sendung einzuleiten.
Genau, das Ende der Sendung geht immer mit einem Dank der Dankgebührt Daniela Christoph, besonders David, der einen sehr amüsanten,
Betreff für seine Spende hatte Fabian auch ganz besonderes und den äh Gästen bei Methodisch Incorrect die.
Schon gedankt haben, aber die wir.
Immer doppelt danken.
Nicht Geduld Gedanken kann. Ja, das war's. Wir machen heute mal kurz ist das eine kurze Sendung, ist eine relativ kurze Sendung geworden. Für unsere Verhältnisse ist es eine große Sendung geworden. Tschüss. Ciao, ciao.
Ciao ciao.